اليومي للمتحدث باسم الجيش
الاسرائيلي اذا ما كنتم تسمعون الان نحن
لن ننساكم ولم ننساكم نحن نفكر بكم كل
الوقت لا تنازل ولا احد يتنازل هناك جهود
وطني كبير وظيفتنا
هو ان نعمل مع اجهزه الامن المختلفه بان
نوفر الظروف عادتكم جميعا نحن سنواصل
العمل بكل الجهود من اجل ان نقوم بهذه
المهمه في الاسابيع
الاخيره ركزنا في القتال في خان يونس
وهناك يتركز القتال التي هي تشكل العاصمه
لحماس في جنوبي قطاع غزه وايضا في منطقه
54 م هناك بنيه تحت الارض
ارهابيه وهو منطقه ماهوله بالسكان وقرى
ومناطق زراعيه
كثيره هناك تحت فرقه فانوس اربع كتائب
لحماس في الاسابيع الاخيره قوات جيش
الدفاع عملت بشكل خاص بتفكيك الاطر
العسكريه لحماس تم القضاء على كتبه ونحن
نعمل الان في منطقه غرب خانيونس
وتم القتال تم قتل
واستسلام
المخربين ويقوم المخربون هناك بعمليات
فرديه
وتم القضاء على اكثر من 2000 مخرب وتحت
الارض وايضا دمرنا بنا تحتيه تحت الارض
وايضا وجدنا هناك مناطق لاحتجاز المخطوفين
وايضا معلومات الفرقه 98 تحارب في المنطقه
وقوات بريه وقوات خاصه وهندسيه وقوات خاصه
وايضا جهاز الامن العام معهم و عمليه
مركبه فوق الارض وتحت الارض في نفس الوقت
هي طريقه حرب جديده وايضا هوها اكثر
التقدم والتطور
وايضا امور يتم استخدام المره الاولى في
الاسبوع الاخير في غربي خان يونسك تم
اعتقال اكثر من 300 من المتهمين بالارهاب
وتم التحقيق معهم هؤلاء يقدمون لنا
معلومات مهمه في حول حماس في غزه وبشكل
خاص في منطقه خان يونس نحن نهاجم مخربين
وايضا في مناطق اختبائهم بالايام الاخيره
عندما قوات يهل مع جهاز الامن العام تم
الكشف عن احد الانفاق
لحماس القوات دخلت الى هذه وكان هناك
ثلاثه من مخربي حماس الذين استسلموا
استسلموا لقواتنا هذه العمليه التي تجري
تحت الارض المخربون تم نقلهم لتحقيق جهاز
الامن العام ويقدمون معلومات هامه وجهود
مثل هذه الجهود ادت الى اعتقال مخربين
كانوا متداخلين في السابع في هجوم السابع
من اكتوبر في مذبح السابع من اكتوبر وايضا
في مقابل القوات البريه ايضا يتم هناك
القص بسلاح الجو
وايضا على اهداف حماس ان يكون فيها مواقع
عسكريه
مخازن اسلحه ومناطق
مراقبه وايضا تهدد قواتنا في
المنطقه مع بدايه الهجوم بدانا فتحنا
مسارات امنه من اجل ان نقل السكان الى هذه
المناطق ومنع استخدام حماس لهم كدروع
بشريه ايضا في هذه العمليه تم نقل اكثر من
100000 من نقل السكان الى غربي من غربيه
ثان يونس لوحدها
نحن نبذل الجهود من اجل ان نمنع حس من
اطلاق الصواريخ كما حدث اليوم ايضا هجمنا
ودمرنا العشرات من منصات اطلاق الصواريخ
ان ادعوكم ان تستمعوا الى توجيهات الجبهه
الداخليه نحن نواصل الهجوم في منطقه خان
يونس ولدينا عمليات
و عمليات ضد كتائب
نحن نواصل تعميق هذا الانجاز
وايضا
بالمقابل تعمل الفرقه 62 في بقيه خان يونس
في الليل تم الهجوم على في شمالي قطاع غزه
على اهداف ارهابيه في
الشاطئ وتم النجاح في هذه العمليه وخلال
ساعات